[Music]
all right
I'm really excited this is my first time
at data Council and have a lot of really
interesting topics to go cover with
everybody so let's get started we're
going to talk about smart orchestration
have a whole host of things that were
going to go touch on here but really
gonna spend most of our time talking
about why pipelines suck and how we
could go build a really cool new control
plane that makes life a lot easier so if
you build data pipelines if you've done
this for a while this will probably make
a lot of sense and be a really
interesting topic for you a quick little
bit of introduction ascend IO
one of the sponsors here we have a booth
back there we are a four year old
company roughly thirty folks mostly
engineering then building our product
and technology for four years now and
TOD are on us is we absolutely love data
pipelines we have a long background
experience building them for myself I've
been building data pipelines for about
15 years now I started my career back at
Google way back when as a software
engineer on front-end thought I was
going to be doing all of this great
front-end code and quickly found myself
writing more MapReduce jobs analyzing
our results then I actually did
front-end engineering
I've really spent the last 15 years then
building out companies and teams and
products in and around data and
engineering one of the really
interesting things that hopefully
capture some folks attention here is out
of send one of the really exciting skill
moments we hit a while back was the
ability to actually process over a
trillion records flying through our
system in a single day and it's funny
because size and scale usually catches
people's attention but I think there's
something far more interesting than just
pushing large numbers of records and
bits and bytes through the system I'm
going to talk about that a little bit
because in the process of doing that it
was also hundreds of thousands of SPARC
jobs that were all intelligently and
automatically orchestrated and that's
gonna be one of the really interesting
themes to cover
here today quick bit about us and just
give you a little bit more context
around the technology we're talking
about and where it sits in our tech
stack our whole fundamental belief is
that we should be able to build smarter
pipelines in less code sounds fantastic
really where we spend a lot of our time
and where we're going to talk today is
this system that underpins a lot of this
the core technology that orchestration
layer that makes it so that we can write
pipelines to connect any data source any
format any transformations and feed it
into other systems and so we're going to
spend a lot of time around how do we
create that highly intelligent control
plane they can do really smart things
for us and with our data alright so I
want a little bit more of the meat
despite the advancements that we've seen
and that I've certainly seen and pretty
much every part of the data lifecycle
building pipelines still kind of sucks
it's funny over the last 15 years I've
watched a lot of the industry of all
I've written all there used all the
early versions of Hadoop to sparked a
storm have used many of the technologies
on this slide and many others that have
simply died off but it's been really
interesting when we think about the
maturity of our data ecosystem today
there's a lot of really powerful
technologies out there right we can
process more data faster at larger scale
to really advance things with though
with our data yet as data engineers as
we create all these pipelines that fuel
all of this great downstream innovation
we're still stuck spending the vast
majority of our time up here and this I
found really frustrating over the course
of the last decade as I was building and
using a lot of this technology and so
you know really the the core goal that
we've set out to solve is how do we make
that part easier ah and to do that you
really have to explore why do pipelines
suck you know back in the day when we
could fit everything inside of the
database inside of a data warehouse life
was really easy all right like you do
I'm a bunch of data in you read a lot of
sequel and
it gets pumped through the millions of
lines of brilliant code that the
database engineers wrote and you get
your results and I was actually pretty
cool and simple when we start to think
about data pipelines however we're no
longer pulling data out of a warehouse
we no longer have a database engine a
query planner or a query optimizer that
does a lot of our job for us and makes
life easier when we start to move to
data pipelines we're now pushing data
through and it introduces a whole host
of new challenges that we have to go
solve for we have to figure out how do
we look and watch for new data what
format does it sit in how do we profile
and partition that data because we need
that information to figure out where we
push it next the short version of this
is every stage of every data pipeline
that we create or essentially
re-implementing query planner and
optimization heuristics we're just
pushing stuff through as opposed to
pulling it out and this part to me when
we started to send four years ago just
seemed absolutely crazy like it seems
like we're solving the same problem over
and over and over again and we should be
able to tackle this once and for all so
when we looked at a lot of the ecosystem
today and I'm guessing most folks around
around the room here have worked with
some of these technologies and I
certainly worked with most of them when
we looked at the evolution of the
ecosystem we've seen a few moves right
we've seen from the sort of cron newsy
Louie Jian and now airflow era we've
seen the move towards sass offerings
more templatized
augmenting pure codebase with GUI based
technology as we move to some of the
sass vendors but what we've also seen is
nothing has really moved around the
design of the control system itself or
the programming model we're still using
schedulers that are based off of timers
and triggers in a very task centric and
we're still following an imperative
engineering model so hang on there's a
few of these in there so we start to
look around for ideas in adjacent spaces
because we can't be the only ones trying
to solve this problem or dealing with
these category of challenges so quick a
few surveys here for the
how many people here have used databases
it's a really easy one all right
how many people here have heard of react
awesome people use it on a regular basis
in case you for a data engineer you're
probably a smaller group yep
cool what about kubernetes Kate's fans
people use it people heard of it yeah
awesome what do they all have in common
they're declarative they all leverage
declarative programming paradigms and
apply it with a control flow or a
control plane to automate a lot of the
underpinnings of that that challenge so
when we think about declarative
programming its apron it's a programming
paradigm that allows us to express logic
that describes the flow as opposed to
actually implementing it it allows us to
eliminate or at least minimize a lot of
the side effects and allow the the
program to actually optimize on our
behalf
simply put it allows us to describe the
what as opposed to the hell and we've
seen this move across a number of
different domains over the course of
time so let's think a little bit more
about these trade-offs the clarity
promise you there's gonna be some more
declarative and what we really want to
go after is ultimately the desired
outcome right there's Simpsons fans
Homer loves his beer that's what he
wants beer you get two different
approaches the what or the how and it
cleared of model he described what he
wants and the imperative model he's got
to go figure out how to brew zone what
we have found over the course of time is
this generally leads to different
outcomes regardless of the desired State
I've spent many many many nights
weekends and days on the right they're
incredibly frustrated with trying to
build and maintain and often
it's my data pipelines others all right
yeah there we go so let's get a little
bit more specific trade-offs between
declarative imperative then we're gonna
dive into how we do that
declarative systems the the pros are
really pretty stark right they are less
code faster dev cycles they can be far
more adaptive to changes in the
environment and ultimately they provide
less maintenance burden for us one of
the reasons why that they're they're so
hard and why we don't see as many of
them however as their domain-specific
they actually require a context and
understanding of that particular domain
in this case data pipelines which means
they're incredibly hard to build they
also can be difficult to manually
optimize they're highly automated
systems and as a result often times
don't give way to really custom tuning
and that high degree of flexibility
conversely when we look at imperative
the reason that we see most technologies
when first introduced into new domains
the imperative is there they're simpler
to introduce you get incredibly high
degrees of flexibility incredibly high
degrees of control the challenge that
you get however is you have to maintain
state and as a result you end up having
a lot more complexity inside of your
imperative based systems because of this
need for state you have to do things
like track that and determine based on
current state what tasks must come next
means that a lot of your code and your
assumptions baked into your code are
stale the moment you ship them they're
from a snapshot in time as opposed to
having to a system that can adapt to
those new understandings of the
environment so put a different way a
great quote by our CTO Stephen parks
who's right down here is imperative
gives you the ability to do anything it
also gives you the responsibility to do
everything and that's the fundamental
trade-off ease-of-use and speed versus
flexibility and control so let's talk
about
building of a declarative control plane
for data pipelines Southpark pens
anybody know the underpant knowns
yes all right this is how we started we
basically started our journey with this
master plan which was we need to do
something around declarative pipelines
and there's gonna be something really
big in the middle we're not sure what
yet but ultimately we should profit so
we spent a lot of time thinking about
what should a good control system do for
data pipelines and we came up with a
massive list of things to do for those
of you who have built data pipelines and
data systems and pass probably have a
lot of features and functions like this
a lot of these are the things that we
only have to do because we don't get a
database engine because we don't get a
query planner or an optimizer these are
essentially the core features and
functions of what a pipeline engine
would look like and then we spent what
we thought was going to be one year and
then two years and then three years
building us and we actually launched our
company out of stealth about excuse me
four months ago really having built out
a lot of this technology and backed by
that sort of core backbone of this
control plane but let's spend time now
talking about how does this actually
work core design and an architectural
principle as you create a declarative
system that's fueled by a control plane
is you have to have separation of logic
and control you need a higher level
blueprint that is your logic plane and
your control plane is the system that
understands that and dynamically
generates the tasks to derive a new
state itself so we're gonna spend most
of our time really focused on that
control plane when we think about the
control plane the control plane system
must be able to answer the following
questions first is there anything I need
to do that's really based off of the
answers to the following ones which is
what is the current state of my world a
job of a dynamic control plane is to
take you from one state to another and
as a result you must know where you
stand to be able to generate any
possible task that could take you to
another state
simple enough third what should my state
be followed by what doesn't match
alright a good control system is doing
this many many times a second across
many many many elements and then
ultimately how do I fix it
so let's dive into a little bit more
depth around how we accomplish this for
data pipelines for those of you who have
built data pipelines in the past let's
think about is there anything I need to
do and take a really simple analytic
type line illustration we've designed a
lot of these we've probably written them
up on whiteboards in the past and they
usually look something like this which
is I have a bunch of files that are
sitting and somewhere a blob store most
likely let's call it s3 they are sitting
on this path here's some creds to go
find them and they probably have this
schema it could be one file a day it
could be one file a second it could be a
thousands of records or billions of
records it shouldn't really matter
there's data it's sitting on this path
let's do something with it a second
piece is what am I doing with data right
so let's say I'm doing a classic sort of
cleaning and Richie and then analyzing
pipeline I'm probably doing some filters
some join some enrichment and then
feeding it into some sort of a
transformation that's compressing the
volume of data down into something I
could then go put inside of the database
aggregating on different dimensions of
users compressing it down and doing
counts and various other aggregations by
our day week you you name it and I'm
trying to make sure that that databases
or that data set is actually properly
synchronized with a database all purely
at a logical error has not yet actually
been applied to data then we get into
some of the interesting stuff which is
that Seki question what is the current
state of my world what I did is over the
weekend actually listed out some of the
the underlying bucket in this case it's
Google Cloud storage and I listed out
the files that were in my bucket and
there's tons and tons and tons of them
but what's really interesting is when I
think about what's there
it's kind of hard to make sense of right
it's basically my bucket some UUID and
then some part files but the magic is
really what do we track with that notion
of a UUID as that starts to link in our
entire understanding of state that UUID
is a fragments UUID with that individual
fragment with every single piece of data
control plane needs to have a bunch of
information about it there's things like
the data shop which is really easy but
not the most helpful thing you're gonna
track some of the more interesting
things that we track that are incredibly
helpful are things like the data profile
what's the min the max the cardinality
of every single column what does it span
this helps us and for what could be
downstream calculations that would
depend on that over time things like job
statistics what generated this piece of
data what files fed into this piece of
data over the spark parameters that we
ran to actually process this piece of
data when did we do it how long did it
take how much memory how many CPUs you
name it all of those statistics this
helps us have a lot of context around
this piece of data but then the really
important part that we have is this
notion of a P shop and this is actually
one of the most key elements in creating
a declarative system and the control
plane is being able to track this pshah
it's a special kind of shop and we're
going spend a lot of time talking about
shah's the pshah is a unique Sean not
just of the data but essentially the
journey of how that data arrived at the
state in the system so we think about it
for source data think about pshah is
just the D shop
it's unique fingerprint itself but the
pshaw
when we get to downstream derived
datasets is a combination it is Shahs of
Shaw's for example we track we actually
shot that transform the code itself that
generated that piece of data it gives us
a unique fingerprint to say if this
piece of code changes to this
transformation changes we know then as a
result that the data set itself should
and needs to change we also then saw
with that
all of the input shots the P Shahs of
the inputs itself recursively traversed
back up the graph a lot there in a
single formula and yes it is my
pseudocode but this is the basic gist of
it is if any of the upstream data
changes if an originating piece of data
changes its D shot and the shots
downstream from it will change if a
transform if the logic I'm applying to a
piece of data changes its sha will
change and this downstream calculations
will also change and so in in the
simplest form this allows us to very
quickly and easy easily say should this
piece of data still be here
what is its unique fingerprint and
allows us to do it without actually
having to look at the data itself we can
simply look at their originating data
and the transforms applied to that piece
of data this allows us to short-circuit
a lot of processes around having to
actually apply transforms just to see if
the data is changed or not so we're
going to spend some more time on this
and a bit but the pshah is incredibly
important so moving on to question
number three what should it be what
should my current state be from question
number two we started from the bottoms
up we looked at all of the data and said
what are the p shah's what are the
fragments that I currently have in my
system itself
step three is let me now look from the
logic plane down and figure out what do
I expect and create a separate that
second set so for that we enumerate
through all the various components and
the transformations people have created
we then look through all their various
partitions and we start to analyze a
bunch of things we analyze the
transforms if its sequel is it a map as
it a reduction is it a partial reduction
if it's a PI spark transform we look for
hints from the user to tell us the same
piece of information this allows us to
then determine what are the actual input
partitions for this transform from there
we can then load up the up stream the
profiles of the data from the upstream
components themselves and look at their
shots and figure out what those pieces
are suit generate RP shots and we
recursively traverse up not just at a
component level but all the way down for
each and every single partition
information and probably get the sense
to this search has become incredibly
expensive computations over the course
of time so we'll spend a little bit of
time later talking about how our
scheduling system can do this multiple
times a second across what could be
hundreds of millions or even billions of
partitions so we talked about the
performance things later but the
ultimate model for this is generate in a
data set of things that are there and
things that should be there and then we
sort of look for what doesn't match this
becomes pretty clearance rate for right
as you're enumerated what you expect to
be there you're looking at its inputs if
the input for a component doesn't exist
or it's pshaw doesn't exist they need to
cue it to get updated to essentially be
regenerated and repaired if all your
data exists but your pshaw doesn't match
then you need to also queue yourself up
for updating there's a pretty simple
step from there to just simply start to
queue up the work to update P shots and
actually I should say not even update P
shots and generate new P shots and new
fragments and then the fifth is fixing
it's only at this step where we actually
can start to generate work and say well
I need to generate and update this new
fragment that is that is aligned with
this pshaw what is the work required I
already know the transform I can rewrite
and optimize it I know what the input
partitions are let me go generate the
work required to to create this new P
shop so we basically have all this
information available we analyze the
input we can consult a bunch of the
statistics from previous runs and from
the inputs themselves and then we can
generate the job pretty simple in
straightforward from there you also get
the benefit of we can then start to
monitor and watch for that job and even
when it's done we committed and this
gives you a lot of the ability to
atomically commit at a metadata layer
everything that has been processed now
let's talk about how we scale this
because this is really cool and really
powerful
system but you also introduced a bunch
of really interesting challenges how do
you traverse what could be a billion
partitions that are generating and
processing a trillion records every
single day and how do you actually run
that that loop and run that process in
less than a second so there's a few core
tenants especially as we scale that
control plane one of the things I
mentioned was Shaw's we do lots and lots
of Shaw's this allows us to
short-circuit having to actually look at
the underlying data itself and or even
generate jobs that may produce duplicate
data everything gets a unique
fingerprint which makes the system
really fast and efficient second
obviously standard principle cache we
cache everything it gives us lots of
performance gains but this when applied
to a really unique approach has given us
some of the biggest games of all which
is something we all learned in
introductory computer science courses
which our trees are better than less
won't more often than not they're
certainly more performant but we create
tree structures that are really
interesting
we actually leverage the fact that our
largest data sets also happen to be time
series data one of the few data sets
that grows over time and as a result
they have unique characteristics where
we can load up that data and structured
in ways based off of our understanding
of the data itself this allows us to do
things like every eight all of the
metadata we know that if the data is
coming in in a year-month-day our
partition structure we can actually roll
up an aggregate at each and every single
node within the tree so we don't have to
traverse that entire tree moreover we
can generate shah's and persist the
shah's even at node levels so we can
rapidly assess has any shot change at
any node in the tree for example has
anything in the data set from 2008
changed if that shot itself hasn't
changed I don't even need to traverse
any part of that tree as a result huge
efficiencies there the last one is be
lazy our system has
figured out how to not have to walk the
entire data set but instead start with
high-priority items and traverse until
it's done and the notion of done is not
have I generated every piece of work
that's required but instead have I
saturated the resources I have we've
added in the ability to monitor all of
our underlying infrastructure we know
how many nodes how big is an auto scale
- how much memory how much CPU and we
pair that with the resources we allocate
for each and every single job and as a
result we know when we've saturated the
underlying infrastructure and can simply
wait for a job to complete this also
helps us give it helps give us a benefit
of knowing if a task was completed it
may have new derived work once that task
is completed so we can simply wait and
make sure that we're always processing
the highest priority tasks now let's
talk about the data plane so scaling the
data plane has also been really really
fun one is do less work so we do less
work by doing a handful of things one is
we persist a ton of intermediate data
just as I think many of you have
probably tried to do in your data
pipelines we are able to persist which
then pushes a lot of the burden back to
storage as opposed to compute storage
tend to be very very cheap by comparison
and that persistence layer is really
enabled by this pshah calculation the
second thing that we do is we also D
duplicate a ton of work remember if I'm
traversing all of the components in a
graph that are being processed at a
certain level I don't even know any
longer what component it is I just know
that there must be a pshaw that exists
somewhere and so we get this really cool
ability where because I'm just simply
looking up and figuring out is has a
data set been generated that aligns with
this pshaw you get all this great out of
benefit of deduplication as a result
it's actually really hard to get the
system to not deduplicate work it has a
result the other thing is making sure
you do the right kind
work spark for example is fantastic when
it's dealing with a smaller number of
really large files it's not so good when
it's dealing with a large number of
really small files or just a large
number of jobs in general
so we've interested a lot in doing
things like small file aggregation
optimizing smaller jobs and even have
created our own specialized pools that
are designed for things like smaller
dots and then the last one I'm talk
about this a couple more slides to a
little bit is make sure you do it
efficiently we've built out a whole
fabric that runs on Azure AWS or Google
cloud we put everything on kubernetes
and we try and leverage as many spot and
preemptable instances as possible or
almost to the point hopefully soon where
we can do low priority VMs on Azure with
our auto scaling spark in cakes clusters
as well then lots of cool little tricks
like single zone clusters one of the
things we found for example is running
multi zone or multi ez clusters in spark
is really expensive as you start to
shove data across availability zones
even if it's fractions of a cent per gig
really starts to add up but in a world
where these clusters can be rather
ephemeral and actually move data around
and pop up new clusters this gave us
huge performance gains and cost
improvements as well now salsify in it
we won't go into too much detail here
but everything that we've created
obviously around this control plane our
entire tech stack is very heavily based
on communities most of our services run
either and Stella which is all the
things that basically touch data to know
mostly be in Scala a lot of our backing
code is written in go which is really
performant as well and then on our front
end we are also a node and react fans so
a lot of these services are have really
been tuned we talked to your PC which is
a lot of us to actually be pretty
language agnostic as to how our systems
communicate with each other and we do
keep a pretty clean separation between
that control
and data plane as a result last few bits
really fast there's a whole lot of
topics we didn't discuss garbage
collection the multi cloud abstraction
layer how do things like data repair
tons and tons and tons of other topics
has I mentioned we've been at this for
four years now so there's a lot of stuff
to discuss come ask me come ask Steven
or the rest of our team who's running
around with some of the pipeline shirts
and we have office hours in 4th floor
room 476 now just bring it back home
really fast
Tod are just to make sure that we recap
this the move from imperative
declarative in concept is pretty simple
and straightforward right it's shifting
the way we think about how we data
engineer it's moving away from the house
right impaired of itself is I inspect
state I Ron tasks and I generate data
and it's moving to declare the
declarative model simply put is focusing
on the what I design logic it's applied
to data and the tasks are simply a
byproduct of that this ultimately does
allow us to create smarter pipelines in
far less code I think that's it if you
guys have questions happy to answer them
we'll see you in office hours we also
have a booth out back in the back room
Regas and see a bunch of the technology
at work as well I think I hit my 30
minute mark all right
[Music]